i have so many jobs i uber i lift i task
rabbit i get paid by creeps online to
watch me eat bananas i do a little elder
care oh [ __ ] what
what what
sorry i just have to do one thing real
quick no i have a meeting i know but
this will just take one second please
pretty please fine fine fine great
what's the hammer for
hammering be right back
what the [ __ ]
[Music]
nearly done just wrapping up oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] you
oh [ __ ]
hey i'm just gonna get another uber no
no i'm done
i'm done
[Music]
would you mind sliding down a ton i'm
gonna need a little room for this guy no
no no no no no no
no
no
so you're probably wondering about the
snake yeah i'm wondering about the
[ __ ] snake that's exactly what i'm
wondering about jillian g it's all
completely above both the state of
florida pays me to do this job check it
out i've got a pamphlet
ten years ago there was a trend for
people to get burmese pythons as pets
they start out really cute they can't be
true it is but then they got too big so
everyone drove their snakes out to the
swamps and set them free but they're not
from here so nothing eats them but they
eat everything birds okay alligators
even other snakes fast it's an
ecological disaster so the state pays
removal agents a hundred bucks for every
dead python we bring in it's a quick and
easy way to earn some extra cash didn't
seem easy they're not craziness they're
really slow they're like big hot dogs
that can bite you or squeeze you to
death but also
they can kind of smile you know this has
been very informative and all that but
you think we hey hey it's the lion you
didn't kill it [ __ ] okay okay again stay
calm just remember it's more scary than
you are
come on look at that skills
sometimes you lose all sorts of reasons
that doesn't help his own neck
[Music]
okay so i kind of feel like i owe you an
apology
you were right the window thing worked
you killed the snake that's not what you
should be apologizing for jillian g what
do you think i should be sorry about
everything the generalities of this
whole situation
okay but the window thing was super
smart so many people overlooked the
cerebral aspect of snake killing
hey
would you ever want to team up your
brains my hammer i just want to get to
my meeting
does your car still drive oh yeah for
sure i'll just throw it in reverse and
get you there in no time my special suit
i can't show up looking like this
not a problem i have clothes you could
change into
do you live in there yeah it's great i
got a bed i got a couple garbage bags of
my things
that's pretty much it what do you go to
the bathroom starbucks it's actually
awesome it is does your bathroom get
cleaned twice a day look this is very
nice and more than a little bleak but i
don't think you have anything in there
that'll fit me
oh really
the hell is that my graduation gown
florida school of excellence class of
07. go titties
the old mascot was racist so they let
the students vote on a new one
[Music]
[Music]
you